Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard schönen
guten Morgen Markus er freue mich
wahnsinnig dich heute zu hören weil ich
dir unbedingt eine Frage stellen muss
dann macht das unbedingt hast du hast du
auch das Erlebnis gehabt in dieser Woche
dass du Menschen auf der Straße triffst
die dich bitten affengeräusche zu machen
ja also ich bin tatsächlich schon
angegrunzt worden und habe das auch im
ersten Moment missdeutsche also wenn
jemand dir nahe kommt und grunzt
empfindest du schnellst ja unter
Menschen also eher so nach dem Motto hau
ab du Arsch also genau gegenteilig als
es bei Gorillas gemeint ist aber es war
ganz lieb und versöhnlich gemeint ist
das gut ist das gut und du warst doch du
warst doch bei Jane gut an
direkt nach unserer Aufnahme ja ich war
bei was ihr zum Interview getroffen
weil meine Sendung im ZDF ja
zehnjähriges Jubiläum hatte und ich
durfte mir einen Gast Wünschen frei wie
ich wollte also einzig unter der
Voraussetzung dass er natürlich zusagt
und ich hatte mal vor fast zehn Jahren
mit Jane go Dell ein wunderbares ganz
ganz langes dreistündiges Gespräch in
der britischen Botschaft in Wien und die
Frau hat mir so dermaßen imponiert dass
ich mir wieder gewünscht habe und sie
hat mir wieder imponiert sie ist 88
Jahre alt und ihr kommt so eine
charmante tastmädchenhafte
ältere Dame gegenüber wie ganz
liebenswürdig ist aber wenn es hart auf
hart kommt ein Gesichtsausdruck hat mit
dem man eine Lokomotive aufhalten kann
und die Kombination finde ich bei Frauen
großartig und macht auch keine keine
Gefangenen sozusagen ne argumentativ
macht keine Gefangenen und wenn Sie
zwischendurch unterbrochen wird ja oder
jemand sie stört oder nervt ja dann
macht sie schimpansenartige
Gesichtsausdrücke oder laute die
wirklich beeindruckend sind also sie
kann von einer Sekunde auf die anderen
auf Schimpanse machen und wirkt dann
auch wirklich richtig aggressiv
und du hast bei ihr zu Hause nee wir
haben uns in bornmist getroffen das ist
der Ort aus dem sie kommt und wo sie
jetzt lebt okay also sie lebt jetzt im
hohen Alter mit ihrer Schwester
gemeinsam im Ort ihrer Kindheit ach süß
also wenn sie mal zu Hause ist die alte
Dame ist immer wahnsinnig viel als
naturbotschafterin unterwegs ja die ist
unglaublich aktiv ne ist ja und ganz
ganz beeindruckend wie sie wie sie über
ihre Forschungszeit in den Afrika
erzählt also alles beeindruckend also
die ganze Haltung zum Leben die
Professionalität ja es ist großartig
also ich meine es ist klar niemand auf
der ganzen Welt weiß so viel über
Schimpansen wie sie
und das ist natürlich zutiefst
beeindruckend
wenn du sagst Haltung zum Leben was
meinst Du dann ich meine dass sie diese
Professionalität hat dass sie im
Interview mit 88 Jahren sofort auf zack
ist und dass sie aber aus dem Motto
sofort wieder abschalten kann und in
einen anderen überwechseln
und dass man mit 88 so frei über sich
selbst verfügen kann
und dass man nicht quasi von
körperlichen psychischen Gebrechen oder
geistigen
Beeinträchtigungen irgendwie versehrt
ist das finde ich an ihr unheimlich
inspirierend das ist ein Mensch der der
durch Willen und Energie
zusammengehalten wird
und das ist sehr sehr beeindruckend ja
das ist schön diese diese Energie zu
erleben ich ich deswegen frage ich da so
nach 88 ich ich habe gerade in dieser
Woche war irgendwie keine schöne Woche
was das angeht zwei Menschen verloren
die mir sehr nahe standen der eine war
mein Onkel Alter Südtiroler Bergbauer
mit knapp 90 Jahren fehlte nur noch
einen Monat zusammen 90 Geburtstag
weite Teile meiner Kindheit auf dem
Bauernhof da verbracht ganz idyllisch
ganz ganz schön hat eine große Familie
viele Kinder die der Bruder meiner
Mutter und das war auch so einer das war
einer der mich immer berührt hat weil er
so und der hatte so ein ungebrochenen
Optimismus bis zum Schluss und ich habe
ihn kurz vor seinem Tod noch mal besucht
und gesehen
und das sagt er zu mir Markus weißt du
ich bin ja jetzt bei Facebook aber ich
habe kein Internet hier
sehr schön aber bis zum Schluss bei
Facebook aktiv und hat mir erzählt und
das hat sich mit Nachrichten beschäftigt
der war auch geistig unheimlich rege und
ja war jemand der wichtig war in meinem
Leben und der andere der gestorben ist
ist Dr Thomas Walde sagte der was war
das nicht ja Journalist ja genau genau
ganz prägender Mensch in meinem Leben
der war früher beim sternleiter Ressort
Zeitgeschichte ganz beeindruckender Mann
der dann gestolpert ist über die
berühmten hitlertagebücher er wacht mit
derjenige der diese Bücher mit
eingekauft hat auf diese
jahrhundertfälschung reingefallen ist
Historiker eigentlich von Haus aus hat
den Stern 9,3 Millionen Mark gekostet ja
dieser Fake diese gefälschten Hitler
Tagebücher und wurde dann sozusagen von
Gruner und Jahr vom Stern
strafversetzt zum höchsten bösen
Privatradio und das war mein großes
Glück weil genau der war Chefredakteur
bei Radio Hamburg und das war einer der
dann dort diese Ausbildung zu einem
echten Juwel gemacht hat der dieses
Volontariat ist wahnsinnig begehrt war
damals einer Zeit in der man glaube ich
beim Privatradios auf richtig
intensiver journalistische Ausbildung
jetzt nicht so den Wert gelegt hat weil
man die Mittel dafür gar nicht hatte
aber er hat das gemacht und hat dann
dafür gesorgt dass wir alle möglichen
Ausbildungsstationen hatten ich war bei
der dpa habe damals ein Bericht gemacht
bei dpa Audio über über die
Veröffentlichung von Windows 95 und so
weiter und war dann irrsinnig stolz dass
dieser kleine Beitrag in Namibia dann
von Radio Windhoek abgerufen worden ist
ja das ging dann in alle Welt hinaus und
das war Thomas Walde und der hat mich
hat mich ja hat mich sehr sehr geprägt
man ganz großartiger Journalist
und auch ein gebrochener Mann weil diese
Geschichte hat die natürlich er hat
seine seine ganz große Karriere der wäre
sicherlich jemand gewesen der immer mal
Chefredakteur beim Stern hätte werden
können hat die natürlich verhindert im
Film in stonk übrigens gespült gespielt
von Ulrich Müller
ganz genau ganz genau
Richard ich
hatte
eine interessante Woche unter anderem
mit dem Bundesarbeitsminister mit mit
Hubertus Heil mit dem man viel streiten
kann über viele Dinge und es war auch
wieder zu spüren sozusagen diese der
Versuch das Rentensystem schön zu reden
an dem eigentlichen zu trinken zu reden
ist ja ja genau aber einer der wirklich
im Stoff ist der wirklich drin ist im
Thema und das brachte mich wieder auf
das Thema aber dass wir eigentlich
letzte Woche schon sprechen wollten
Gemeinwohl ja gemein sind
ich ich habe das Gefühl wir müssen was
Gemeinwohl angeht neu nachdenken Dinge
neu denken weil die Rolle die der Staat
da so einnimmt dieses Gefühl um alles
kümmert sich der Staat ich glaube das
ist ein für alle mal vorbei und ich habe
auch das Gefühl wir müssen uns von so
einer von so einem weltgeschichtlichen
Ausnahmezustand verabschieden wenn man
sich anschaut in der
Bundesrepublik in den letzten
Jahrzehnten im Schnitt haben Menschen ja
immer weniger gearbeitet und wurden
parallel dazu immer wohl haben die
letzten die letzten zehn Jahren nicht
mehr ne muss man da genau diese Zeit ist
genau das merken wir jetzt auch alle und
diese Zeit ist vorbei und das bedeutet
wir müssen uns neu und anders
organisieren ja und jetzt kommt eine
Perspektive dazu die da normalerweise
gar nicht reinkommt aber da ich ja
gerade in Lüneburg bin
auf dem Utopie Kongress den wir dort
jährlich veranstalten vier tägige
Kongress und das ist die Perspektive
dass wir jetzt in einigen Bereichen den
enger schneiden müssen ist ja das was
die Leute die sich mit Ökologie
beschäftigen ja schon seit Ewigkeiten
fordern
das heißt also eigentlich tritt doch
jetzt das ein dass wir weniger CO2
verbrauchen dass er weniger
energieverbrauchen erst recht fossile
Energien hier werden ja all die Wünsche
wahr die die Grünen immer gehabt haben
und das Merkwürdige ist dass sie das als
Krise darstellen und nicht als Chance ja
dass wir also sagen wir haben eine
totale Katastrophe ein Ausfall gegenüber
der Normalität und eigentlich müssen wir
tun die Grünen jetzt alles damit wir
wieder in die Normalität zurücknehmen
also jemand kann seine Gasrechnung nicht
mehr bezahlen dann sagen wir ja der muss
natürlich jetzt deutlich mehr Geld
kriegen damit er weiterhin so viel Gas
verbrauchen kann hier immer schon
verbraucht hat obwohl die gleichen
Politiker seit Jahrzehnten predigen dass
wir nicht so viel Gas verbrauchen können
ja ja das finde ich aber das ist die
Paradoxie dieses Winters ja das ist wahr
aber ich ich habe ihn in der
Vorbereitung auf unser Gespräch heute
ganz ganz lange in einem deiner
bekannteren Bücher im Egoisten gelesen
ja die Kunst keine Egoist zu sein und
ich finde da finden sich ja unheimlich
viele Antworten darin du deutet das
gerade an also das eine ist das
Stichwort Verlust Aversion wir können
wir können mit Verlusten können wir ganz
ganz schlecht umgehen und das große
Stichwort ist Status also die Aussicht
Status zu verlieren das ist der Albtraum
irgendwie den den uns glaube ich kein
Politiker zumuten will weil die genau
wissen was das mit so einer Gesellschaft
macht man könnte ja sagen das
Versprechen das ist ein möglich ist
durch Fleiß und Tüchtigkeit
statusgewinne zu erzielen hat dieses
Land wahrscheinlich mehr
zusammengehalten als alles andere ja
warum ist Status so wichtig Richard
psychologischer Status ist im Grunde
genommen ja ein Spiegelbild von dem von
dem man glaubt wie viel Anerkennung man
bekommt
der Reiz von Status ist Anerkennung also
wenn eine Rolex Uhr ja als soziales
schiffre für Wohlstand nicht
funktionieren würde würden
wahrscheinlich die allermeisten Leute
die eine besitzen keine tragen
es geht nicht darum dass das Uhrwerk
besonders präzise ist das ist bei Rolex
Uhren glaube ich ziemlich schlecht
es geht darum dass Leute erkennen der
kann sich alles ziemlich schnell
aber nicht es ist keine Atomuhr das ist
unsere ja also sagen wir mal der Preis
einer Rolex-Uhr und die Präzision des
Laufwerk also nicht zusammen aber genau
das Interessante ist eben man macht das
deswegen oder oder wenn wir in einer
Gesellschaft leben würden in der sich
jeder einen Porsche leisten könnte wäre
Porsche fahren nichts Besonderes ja und
viele Leute die jetzt ein Porsche fahren
würden vielleicht keinen Porsche mehr
fahren bei der Rolex Uhr ist das noch
offensichtlicher als von Porsche ja weil
das Auto vielleicht Spaß macht und die
Uhr an sich ist die Frage der Spaß
besteht doch darin dass sie erkannt wird
und das ist eben das interessante weil
wir glauben über Status kriegen wir
Blicke Anerkennung positive Einordnung
und so weiter und Status bestimmt im
Grunde genommen wir sind ja Primaten ne
wie Gorillas und Schimpansen
Affen und der der bestimmt nach außen
hieß es sozusagen ein sichtbares Zeichen
unserer Rang Zugehörigkeit in der Horde
und wir haben uns da was weggenommen
wird dann wird uns im Grunde genommen
auch unser eigenes Selbstverständnis
weggenommen das interessant ich meine
wenn du mal wenn du es mal andersrum
überlegst wird ja auch ein Schuh draus
ne also Status ist ja was total
faszinierendes finde ich weil also
Status weggenommen hast du gerade
geschildert was damit uns passiert
Status erreicht ist das was wir
anstreben aber bitte nicht alle also
wenn alle sozusagen den den gleichen
Status haben ist Status plötzlich wird
egal absolut das ist faszinierend ein
Status ne also man würde sich versuchen
die verrücktesten Ideen auszudenken über
den man dann doch Status oder die
Wissenschaft sagt distinktionsgewinne
erzielen kann ja weil ich meine alle
Menschen wollen ja das gleiche anders
sein als die anderen und ihm bemühen
anders zu sein irgendwann alle gleich
genau das ist sozusagen die die diales
Gesellschaft genau es faszinierend und
ich fand einen total interessanten
Gedanken dahin in ich glaube in deinem
Buch was dieser Tag auf jeden Fall
Daniel Bell sagt dir was berühmter
Soziologe
Harvard ja liebe Grüße an Karl
Lauterbach der der sagt etwas total
interessant ist der sagt der westliche
Mensch zerfällt heute praktisch in zwei
Teile die nicht zusammenpassen ja so die
Wirtschaft haben wir jetzt gerade
darüber gesprochen benötigt einerseits
diesen egoistischen
unersättlichen hedonistischen
Konsumenten der nie zufrieden ist
disziplinlos ja gierig bis zum Anschlag
weil nur dann stellst du sicher dass wir
ständig Dinge kaufen die wir eigentlich
gar nicht bräuchten
und die Gesellschaft dagegen und das ist
interessant bräuchte ja genau das
gegenseitig die bräuchte ja einen
anständigen bescheidenen hilfsbereiten
zufriedenen zurückgenommenen
bodenständigen
Mitbürger das ist das was der mein
wohlorientiert und so weiter also jemand
der sich nicht vor anderen Vorteile
verschaffen will sondern der auch an die
anderen denkt und so genau und das
Kunststück ist jetzt sag ich mal positiv
das Kunststück ist dass es in unserer
Gesellschaft geglückt ist obwohl diese
Paradoxie besteht dass wir seit sehr
langer Zeit in einer im historischen und
geografischen Maßstab vorbildlichen
Gesellschaft leben bei all dem was ein
Missständen existiert aber dass das so
lange funktioniert hat das finde ich
erstmal beeindruckend ich habe eine
Theorie dazu
habe ich habe ich noch nicht mit meinem
Sohn drüber gesprochen ich glaube ich
habe das schon mal gesagt der sagte zu
mir Papa euer System ist am Ende und
zwar deswegen weil euer Kuchen nicht
mehr wächst solange der Kuchen immer
größer wurde war klar egal wie groß der
Kuchen ist denn Dominik und Lukas dir
jetzt hier gerade gegenüber sitzen ja
wie groß das Stück ist dass ich Dominik
und Lukas nehmen für mich und auch für
dich bleibt immer noch genügend übrig
aber in dem Moment wo der Kuchen kleiner
wird richtig fange ich plötzlich an mich
für das Kuchenstück von Dominik und von
Lukas zu interessieren und dann wird es
gefährlich ja und wir haben gar keine
Erfahrung in der Bundesrepublik mit
kleiner werdenden Kuchen so und jetzt
gibt es natürlich viele Dinge über die
wir oft gesprochen haben warum der
Kuchen kleiner wird und es gibt auch
noch Leute die sagen der Kuchen wird gar
nicht kleiner ne aber wir sollten
zumindestens gut vorbereitet sein dass
er kleiner wird und ich komme wieder mit
der Perspektive von vorhin muss er nicht
aus ökologischen Gründen kleiner werden
ist das nicht sozusagen notwendig haben
wir nicht über unsere ökologischen
Verhältnisse gelebt
und das ist eine Einsicht die wird von
vielen geteilt
aber das Problem ist in dem Moment wo
man die Außen kleiner macht na ja kommt
der kategorische Komparativ den halte
ich für wichtiger als den kategorischen
Imperativ das heißt man guckt immer ganz
ganz ganz genau ob das Eigenart
abgeschnitten wird als vom Stück des
anderen und so eine Diskussion haben wir
jetzt er ist richtig
dabei gibt es ja ich glaube wir haben
schon mal bei ihnen gesprochen wie heißt
der noch mal Rückkehr Brinkmann ja sagt
ihr was ne der sagt mir
holländische Autor genau so ein junger
Historiker sondern mal hintereinander
Vorträge gemacht habt vor dem
niederländischen Königspaar so richtig
genau das hat genau das hast du mir
jetzt sind ja nicht Netti das
niederländische königspavier hast du die
erlebt wahnsinnig nett ja also ich meine
sie ist eine faszinierende Frau ja mit
einer tollen Ausstrahlung die junge Frau
das Argentinien sehr intelligent also
die waren sehr jung als ich das letzte
mal neue Post gelesen habe so muss es
vielleicht nein nein nein großartig
maximal Max kann ich nur gut darüber
sagen und das interessante bei ihm ist
er hat ja so ein bisschen das Klischee
aufgrund eines leicht bollerigen
Aussehens ja nicht der Hellste wäre und
ich muss das Korrigieren ja der ist
schlau ich war beeindruckt was für
gebildete Königspaare es gibt weil es
gibt ja nicht den Selektionsdruck auf
Königspaare besonders gebildet und
intelligent zu sein und sie waren es
trotzdem und das hat mir sehr imponiert
kein schlechtes Wort darüber ja super
herrlich ich muss das mal beichten ich
habe glaube ich die die Vermählung die
Hochzeit der beiden habe ich damals für
RTL als junger Reporter begleitet du
hast nichts ausgelastet du ich war jung
von Mona junge Monat mehr Schandtaten
aus der Jugendhilfe ja es ist wirklich
wahr Chef Reporter des goldenen Blattes
nein nein ich war es sowas ähnliches ich
war bei RTL ich habe dort gearbeitet und
es war einfach eine Live-Übertragung
hallo Es war eine riesen Nummer und ich
fand es schön und du hast der Deckel
Ecke man Sägebrecht oder wie der heißt
oder Eggebrecht segemann gemacht und
hast das kommentiert ja genau der der
der übrigens ein sehr netter Mann ist in
Sicherheit ja übrigens ich liebe diese
Stimme ja du liebst die Stimme und und
er ist erst the one and only und man
weißt du warum ich ihn vor allen Dingen
Schätze nicht wegen seiner königsbericht
Erstattung ist wissen die wenigsten
sondern der war lange Afrika
Korrespondent der weiß ähnlich wie über
Afrika wie du das ist jemand der sich
ganz viel über Korrespondent glaube ich
in Ostafrika hat auch
dann über große Hungersnöte Stichwort ja
Frauen und so weiter berichtet und ist
jemand der ganz viele Zusammenhänge
kennt der hat mich wahnsinnig
beeindruckt irgendwie das Leben dieses
Mannes ist wirklich bewegen
ja meines Wissens lebt er noch ja ich
habe ihn vor ein paar Jahren erst im im
Studio gehabt ein ganz tolles Foto von
ihm gemacht den wir so ein schönes
nachdenkliches Bild
ich finde seine große Leistung besteht
die darin dass etwas was ich so
langweilig finde wie fürstenhochzeiten
und Krönungszeremonien was ich mir nie
angucken würde ja aber wenn diese diese
vornehme
bedeutungsschwangere und anteilnehmende
Stimme ja dir erklärt welche Farben die
Garde zum wievielten geburtstag der
Schwiegermutter des Königs und so weiter
trägerischen und dem eine Bedeutung bei
mir ist dann ist das jemand dem hört man
auch dann zu wenn man denkt dass es die
unwichtigste Frage der Welt aber er kann
diese Bedeutung da reinlegen und das ist
eine Kunst man würde sich wünschen jeder
Lehrer würde über diese Gabe das ist
wirklich wahr aber wir schweifen abrich
hat
Gemeinwohl ja ist das große Stichwort
erinnerst du dich an an
Ackermann den Chef der Deutschen Bank ja
klar ich ich finde total interessant was
ich da verändert hat ich weiß doch der
hat mal gesagt war auch ganz stolz drauf
und das macht er glaube ich in einem in
einem
brieffilm hatte das mal gemacht hat er
erzählt ist dass er Angela Merkel immer
klipp und klar gesagt hat dass er
Angestellter der Deutschen Bank ist und
es dann nicht gegen die Interessen der
Deutschen Bank irgendetwas unternehmen
kann das heißt Gemeinwohl war ihm nicht
weiter wichtig sagt denn einem Film von
Hubert Seipel ja und sagt dann Banken
besonders private und börsennotierte
Institute haben keine Verpflichtung das
Gemeinwohl zu fördern und in dem
gleichen Sinne hat damals auch Alexander
Dibelius der der Deutschland-Chef von
Goldman Sachs argumentiert das ist
interessant da hat sich was verändert ja
gut die Leute also wir könnten bei
meinem zynisch wäre würde man sagen die
Leute waren früher ehrlicher und ich
waren deswegen ehrlicher weil man das
von Banken auch nicht so wirklich
erwartet hat das hat sich natürlich
verändert und klar ist natürlich wenn
wir in einer allgemeinen Phase der
gesellschaftlichen Transformation stehen
und in seiner solchen Phase müssen wir
stehen um das Überleben der
Enkelgeneration dann müssen natürlich
die die besonders weite Schultern haben
und die besonders aktiv an der Front
sind sich an diesem unter anderem
moralischen Aufbruch also eben nicht nur
technischen Aufbruch beteiligen
und ist mir ist ja völlig klar also
Acker man hat ja eigentlich nichts
anderes zitiert als die Logik einer
Aktiengesellschaft genau also Ackermann
ist den Aktionären verpflichtet gewesen
und nicht dem Gemeinwohl und das ist in
einer Sache hat sich das ja nicht
geändert
die Sache ist eben nur das angesichts
der großen menschheitsaufgabe vor die
wir stehen
dieses diese Haltung
so nicht allein zukunftsfähig mehr sein
darf
und ich denke das auch bei großen
Konzernen Banken und Versicherungen und
so weiter das klar ist mittlerweile
mittlerweile klar ist also ich glaube
dass sind ja Äußerungen die ja 2010 oder
2009 gemacht hat und gegenüber heute hat
sich da einiges verändert
meine ganz ganz andere Frage aber in
diesen zehn Jahren hat es natürlich
einen wichtigen Bewusstseinsprozess
gegeben der einfach darin besteht dass
dieses alte wäre ich meine er sagt das
so eine Höhepunkt der merkelzeit also
auf die in einer Zeit in der zwar die
ökologische Krise schon alles klar war
aber nicht in jedermanns Bewusstsein
existierte ja Klimawandel bereits ein
Thema war aber noch nicht so ein Thema
wie es heute ist die Frage was hält eine
Gesellschaft zusammen sich nicht stellen
musste weil der Wohlstand wuchs
dass das so eine Position war wie sie
sehr lange vertreten worden ist und wie
sie jetzt sich stark verändert hat ich
meine das nicht anders wie man konnte
100 Jahre lang Winnetou lesen ohne
schlechtes Gewissen zu haben und auf
einmal geht das nicht mehr also da
verändern sich verändert sich ziemlich
viel das ist wahr sollten wir vielleicht
immer noch meine eigene Ausgabe machen
zu dem Thema großartig wir könnten eine
wunderbare winnetou-sendung eigentlich
ich glaube meine wir hätten uns schon
mal über Winnetou unterhalten aber das
Thema ist nicht erschöpft das Thema ist
offensichtlich nicht erschöpft nee und
und es gibt dass das verrückte in dem
Zusammenhang nur ein Gedanke dazu ist
dass du eigentlich das Gefühl hast als
Mensch der im Jahr 2022 lebt wir
genießen so viele Freiheiten wie noch
nie es gibt so wenige Tabus wie noch nie
wir können so viel sagen wie noch nie
aber ich glaube das ist falsch es gibt
nämlich sozusagen so viele Dinge die
unausgesprochen plötzlich Regeln
geworden süchtig es gibt
oft gesagt wir leben in der neuesten
Gesellschaft die es hier auf deutschem
Boden gab
formal und wir sind persönlich zu einer
Selbstzensur verdonnert die auch ein
historisches Ausmaß an genau die aber
nicht offen offiziell ausgesprochen ist
sondern mehr aber man merkt natürlich in
dem Moment wo man gegen irgendeine
dieser Konventionen von den viele neu
sind verstößt ja was man damit auslöst
aber auch das ist eigentlich ein Thema
ja ist ein Thema sollten wir sollten wir
wirklich mal den eigenen Podcast aber
wird noch mal noch mal gerne zurück
Richards zu dem Thema ich meine die
diese wir haben schon ein paar mal
darüber gesprochen wie sich dieses
Verhältnis sozusagen von Bürger zum
Staat verändert ja
und es gab ja sag mal 90er Jahre und
dann auch später diese Josef Ackermann
Seite über die wir gerade gesprochen
haben das war ja eigentlich so eine Zeit
in dem man eigentlich sagen muss der
Angela Merkel war nicht wirklich an der
Macht sondern Angela Merkel war nur an
der Regierung das was völlig anderes und
das ändert sich gerade dass das
eigentlich lange Zeit immer so war ja
genau
dafür Angela Merkel gilt also man kann
man du kannst gegen gegen die führende
deutsche Industrie nicht regieren muss
immer im Einklang mit ihr regieren das
ist völlig und deswegen gibt es dann
daraus resultierend habe ich das Gefühl
ja so ein bisschen eine
Orientierungslosigkeit und alle spielen
so ein großes Spiel also dann dann sitzt
jemand wie Hubertus Heil der sich sehr
anstrengt von morgens bis abends gestern
mal gehört was die für wahnsinnig lange
Tage haben ja morgens um 6:30 Uhr aus
dem Haus und nachts um 12 Uhr wieder
nach Hause und so weiter das ist
unfassbar also das ist ein richtiger
Knochenjob dann der ersten Reihe der
Politik dass das wird wird dann immer
mal wieder klar wenn man so hinter den
Kulissen mit den Leuten mal so ein
bisschen spricht aber am Ende ist es
auch teilweise eine Illusion also wir
bezahlen die sozusagen dafür oder wählen
Sie dafür dass Sie uns die Illusion
geben wir haben es im Griff wir machen
das alles aber sie sie gaukeln uns zum
Teil weil das System ist so will etwas
vor was in Wahrheit da gar nicht ist
sondern sie haben viel weniger
Möglichkeiten viel weniger Macht zu
gestalten sie sind wahrscheinlich
persönlich auch bei vielen Entwicklungen
sehr viel skeptischer als sie nach außen
zeigen also zum Beispiel da gibt es so
eine Ohnmacht das ist das ist der Punkt
und ich habe das Gefühl wir sind jetzt
gerade an so einem Punkt an dem wir das
alles neu verhandeln müssen und die
Frage woher kann wenn wir diese Egoisten
sind die wir vorhin beschrieben haben
woher kann dieser neue Gemeinsinn kommen
Richard woher das mit den Egoisten ist
ja so eine Sache also es gibt in meinem
Buch thematisiere ich das ja auf
hunderten von Seiten also die Frage was
wahre Menschen Natur ist der Mensch von
Natur aus Egoist oder ist er Altruist
da gibt es ja radikale Sichtweisen die
also Mitte der 70er Jahre hat der
amerikanische Evolutionsbiologe Michael
giselyn den einprägsamen Satz gesagt
kratzt einen Altruisten und du siehst
einen Heuchler bluten
nach dem Motto alles was der Mensch tut
tut er doch immer um etwas davon zu
haben
und ich habe in meinem Buch versucht
herauszustellen dass das eine schlechte
Definition von Egoismus ist richtig ist
alles was wir tun tun wir um irgendetwas
davon zu haben aber die Frage ob du ein
guter oder ein schlechter Mensch bist
oder ein Egoist oder ein Altruist hängt
nicht davon ab dass du von dem was du
tust etwas haben willst sondern es hängt
davon ab was du bereit bist für Mittel
einzusetzen und was du davon haben
willst denn in der Definition von
giselin ist Mutter Teresa eine Egoistin
das hat hier alles nur gemacht um den
Himmel zu kommen oder um das gute Gefühl
zu haben Gutes zu tun moralisch
überlegen das heißt also etwas von etwas
haben zu wollen ist kein Ausweis von
Egoismus
na wenn ich sage da ist jemand der
opfert sich für andere auf aber
eigentlich tut er das ja nur um sich
besonders gut zu fühlen dann ist das
kein starkes Argument weil es immer noch
besser ist jemand opfert sich für andere
auf als er wollte dann raus aus
was tut jemand und nicht ob er was davon
haben will
und wenn wir das so sehen dann kommen
wir zu einer Betrachtung des Menschen
dass wir sagen man kann Egoismus und
Altruismus im Menschen gar nicht sauber
voneinander unterscheiden sondern das
Gute an den Menschen ist ja dass man
sich gut fühlt wenn man Gutes tut und
das liegt ja auch in unserer Natur es
gibt ein paar Menschen da ist das anders
die finden das auch gut irgendwie
bewusst Böses zu tun aber die größten
Verbrechen der Menschheitsgeschichte
wurden nicht von Egoisten begangen oder
von Menschen die mit aller Gewalt Böses
tun wollen ich meine das geht ja dann
auch top-down von oben nach unten wenn
du dir wir haben ja öfter schon über
dieses berühmte Hamburger
Polizeibataillon gesprochen habe 101
glaube ich ne diese diese Männer die
ganz normale Familienväter waren und
dann abkommandiert werden in die
Ostgebiete und dort barbarische
Verbrechen begehen und dann später vor
Gericht aber alle sagen wir sind uns da
keiner Schuld bewusst wir haben nichts
Schlimmes getan wir haben unsere Pflicht
getan ja also wir haben das für uns
nicht selber ausgesucht man hat uns was
aufgetragen und Baby haben nichts
anderes getan als die anderen und ich
habe ja in meinem Buch versucht
herauszuarbeiten was wir für
interessante Tricks haben um unsere
moralische Bilanz gut zu fälschen die
gute Nachricht ist Menschen ertragen den
Zustand die Bösen zu sein im Regelfall
sehr schlecht exakt das heißt wir färben
was auch immer wir tun unsere Bilanz
nachher gut und sagen aber es ist doch
nur und ich wollte doch nur und ich habe
doch nicht
und diese Mittel sind die erst das erste
Mittel ist uns mit anderen zu
vergleichen die schlechter sind als wir
dass der Trainer das ist der eine Trick
und die finden wir immer der zweite
Trick ist wenn jemand kommt und sagte
mal Markus ne du bist kein guter Mensch
dich sofort zu fragen wer sagt mir das
Richard du sagst mir das glaubst du dass
du ein besserer Mensch bist als ich das
heißt also ich gehe auf die Psyche
meines Gegenübers der mir die schlechte
Nachricht bringt ich bin schlechter
Mensch und diskreditiere die Person die
mir die Nachricht überbringt da muss ich
sie nicht mehr ernst nehmen das kannst
du bei Donald Trump immer sehen ne das
ist das ist alle alle alle diese Tricks
hervorragend aber genau den vor allen
Dingen nicht zuständig war eine
schlechte Mitarbeiterin der hat die war
immer schon schwierig also heute muss
man gar nicht zuhören was die sagt und
so weiter ich habe von Richard Kurzmann
den du kennst ja mit dem du diesen
Vortrag vor maximal und genau und und
Wilhelm da gehalten hast so der hat
gerade ein tolles Buch das heißt im
Grunde gut und der vertritt genau diese
These ist ein fantastisches Buch mag das
wahnsinnig allein den Einstieg wie er
erzählt dass die die Engländer als die
Nazis London angegriffen haben davon
ausgegangen sind die Bevölkerung wird
zusammenbrechen die werden alle in die
Knie gehen es wird Panik ausbrechen und
alle Massenmörder der moderneren
Geschichte sind genau von solchen
Horrorszenarien ausgegangen und das
faszinierende ist all das ist nicht
passiert sondern die Leute sind
moralisch stehen geblieben die Leute
haben das ertragen und das Leben ging
weiter und der beschreibt so
Zeugenaussagen oder auch Berichte von
von Psychiatern die kurz nach der
Auslösung des fliegeralarms dann
beschreiben wie kleine Jungs weiterhin
mitten in London auf dem Bürgersteig
spielen ja wie sich Kunden beim falschen
nicht unterbrechen lassen ein Polizist
der weiter da steht und ganz gelangweilt
den Verkehr regelt oder der Radfahrer
der einfach weiter fährt der händ
Mitarbeiter handelt und so weiter das
heißt die Leute ertragen das in absolut
stoischer Gelassenheit und brechen eben
nicht moralisch zusammen und das ist für
ihn unter anderem der Nachweis dafür
dass Menschen eigentlich von Grund auf
nicht nur gut sondern auch wahnsinnig
widerstandsfähig und resilient sind und
du beschreibst eine ähnliches Experiment
nämlich das ein ganz berühmtes
Experiment das eigentlich zeigt dass
Kleinstkinder von Haus aus ohne dass man
sie belohnt unbedingt erstmal das Gute
wollen hilfsbereit hilfsbereit sind
eine natürliche Eigenschaft sozialer
Primaten ja weil das was ich jetzt
erzähle gilt für Kleinkinder genauso wie
für Schimpansen also es liegt in unserer
Natur das kann sich jeder auch auf
Youtube angucken
als ich damals darüber schrieb war es
noch schwer an die Filme ranzukommen
heute sind die auf Youtube eingestellt
Felix warnecken und Michael Thomas hello
Michael tomasellosen großer Star der
Primaten Forschung und der Anthropologie
die haben Experimente gemacht indem sie
ein Menschen gezeigt haben der den in
der Hand laut den großen Aktenstapel hat
und versucht die Tür zu einem Schrank
aufzukriegen er will er die rein tun und
in der Ecke des Zimmers steht ein ganz
kleines Kind ja etwas über ein Jahr alt
kann aber schon laufen was macht dieses
Kind ist sieht der Mann kriegt die Akten
da nicht rein kriegt die Tür nicht auf
geht dahin Tip Tip Tip Tip und hilft ihm
die Tür aufzumachen
und da gibt es viele andere Beispiele ja
jemand fällt ein Stift vom Tisch genau
ja das Kind kommt bückt sich hebt den
Stift auf und reicht den rüber ganz
natürlich menschliches Verhalten
das ist die gute Nachricht aber nicht
anderswogen ne nicht André nicht sondern
erzogen wird sondern intrinsisch das
Problem ist dass wir in einer
Gesellschaft leben in dem diese
intrinsische Motivation ganz ganz häufig
zerstört wird
und zwar durch extrinsische Belohnungen
das heißt die haben das gleiche
Experiment gemacht oder ähnliche
Experimente und haben dann dem Kind für
das Öffnen der Türen oder ein ähnliches
Beispiel eine Belohnung gegeben
fallen hast du das gemacht
die Folge ist dass man fünfmal
hintereinander oder sechs Mal
hintereinander gemacht und am Ende gab
es keine Belohnung mehr und da hat das
Kind nicht mehr geholfen
das heißt der einmal daran gewohnt ist
etwas für eine extrinsische Belohnung zu
tun ja wird sich sehr weigern das
umsonst zu tun obwohl es in seiner Natur
liegt es umsonst zu tun
und was wollt ihr denn daraus viel
Erfolg daraus
er ist viel folgt daraus zum Beispiel
große Konsequenzen für die Pädagogik und
für Schulen für Schulen ja also wenn ich
mich anstrenge um eine gute Zensur zu
kriegen und ich schaffe die Noten ab
dann strengen sich die Kinder nicht mehr
an
es kann jedenfalls passieren also wäre
es am besten man hätte Schulen indem man
erst gar keine Zensuren hätte dann würde
man die intrinse schon Motivation nicht
durch extrinsische Belohnung zerstören
ich bin jetzt keine Verfechter davon
dass man das von heute auf morgen tun
sollte aber ich halte das für ein
erstrebenswertes Bildungsziel
das ist wahnsinnig interessant aber das
hat ja hat ja noch einen Fehler Hinsicht
Auswirkungen also wenn das dass der
stellt ja sozusagen unser gesamtes
System in Frage unsere Art zu leben in
der Lohnarbeit das System der der das
Lernens 14 suchen und so weiter das ist
in der Tat so also das Spannende ist du
sagtest vorhin ne das rückgaberegt man
sagt der Mensch ist gut ich werde ein
bisschen vorsichtiger ich würde nicht
sagen dass er gut oder schlecht ist
sondern ich würde sagen der Mensch ist
ein sozialer Primat der auf Anerkennung
angewiesen ist und wenn er in einer
Kultur lebt in der gutes Verhalten
belohnt wird dann ist belohnt muss nicht
unbedingt mit Geld sein das kann ja auch
einfach sein mit Richtung oder mit
Freude oder was man auslöst
dann ist es recht wahrscheinlich dass
jemand das internalisiert wenn ich aber
jetzt in einer Umgebung aufwachse ja wo
nur besonders kriminelles oder asoziales
Verhalten belohnt wird dann werde ich
mich wahrscheinlich in eine ähnliche
Form entwickeln aus demselben Motiv
Anerkennung zu bekommen das heißt also
der idiotischen Umgangsform in
Gefängnissen und auf seeräuberschiffen
sind einfach andere ja als in einem
Montessori-Kindergarten ist richtig und
wie Menschen sich verhalten verrät
deswegen oft ganz wenig über die
menschliche Natur sondern vielmehr über
Anpassungsprozesse
und das bedeutet dass zum Beispiel
friedliche Gesellschaften meistens
ziemlich viele friedfertige Menschen
hervorbringen und kriegerische
Gesellschaft und zum Beispiel sehr viele
Krieger also so ein kriegerstaat wie
Sparta hat er wenig Probleme damit
ausreichend Soldaten zu finden ein Land
wie die Bundesrepublik Deutschlands im
Jahr 2022 ja da sehe die Situation
völlig anders aus
in deinem Buch gibt es auch viele
interessante Beispiele zum Thema Moral
und Wirtschaft Name schon ein bisschen
darüber gesprochen über über Josef
Ackermann und so weiter an der sich
sozusagen dem Gemeinwohl nicht
verpflichtet fühlte dieser Tage
Christian sewing gehört den neuen Chef
der Deutschen Bank der sagten erst das
Land und dann das Unternehmen also da
scheint sich tatsächlich etwas
fundamental zu ändern unter dem Eindruck
auch der Krisen mit dem wir gerade zu
tun haben ja Corona war das eine der
Krieg in der Ukraine ist ist das Land
Sanktionen so ist ist das genau wie weit
müssen wir gehen und was müssen wir dann
auch irgendwann auch aushalten welche
Abstriche sind wir bereit in Unternehmen
so das ist die Frage und wenn wenn
rückgab brägt man recht hat und sagt der
Mensch ist im Grunde nach gut
glaubst du denn dass wir wirklich
ernsthaft bereit werden wirklich
Abstriche zu machen also ich habe noch
keinen gehört auch von Seiten der
Politik der sich wirklich traut den
Leuten das klipp und klar zu sagen
ja also ich finde das ist eine
unglaublich spannende Frage weil ich
hatte ja schon beim letzten Mal gesagt
wir machen ein gigantisches
Sozialexperiment wahrscheinlich das
größte in der Geschichte unseres Landes
im Hinblick auf die Frage wenn das
tatsächlich so sein sollte dass wir
nicht ausreichend Gas im Winter haben
wie wir als Gesellschaft damit umgehen
und ob der Brig mancher Effekt dann
eintritt dass die Menschen sich da brav
anpassen oder wie heftig der Widerstand
ist
und mir fehlt eigentlich jeder Kompass
oder jeder Instinkt um zu sagen ob das
zu etwas größeren Unruhen vor allem im
Osten führen wird
oder ob es nicht dazu führen wird ich
weiß nicht wie lange haben wir uns schon
mal drüber ausgetauscht ich bin mir ganz
sicher mittlerweile ich habe da noch mal
lange drüber nachgedacht im Nachgang
auch an unser letztes Gespräch ich bin
mir ganz sicher dass es nicht so sein
wird ich bin mir ganz sicher die Leute
werden stehen bleiben auch wenn du die
diese Kriegserfahrungen mal durchliest
von denen bringt man da berichtet mit
Blick auf die Londoner aber auch das
gibt es ja analog auch auf der anderen
Seite in Deutschland dieses Land ist aus
einer unglaublichen aus einer
unglaublichen Katastrophe heraus zu dem
geworden was es heute ist und da hat
sich der wahre Charakter des Menschen am
Ende auch gezeigt und ich glaube dass er
recht hat und dieses Beispiel des
Kleinkindes dass ich unaufgefordert
sofort bückt um dir zu helfen wenn du
irgendwann Probleme hast du siehst es
auch bei kleinen Kindern wenn jemand
weint welche Empathie die plötzlich
entwickeln egal wie gassig sie vorher
möglicherweise waren das ist ganz ganz
erstaunlich und deswegen denke ich
manchmal und das ist doch eigentlich die
Frage
wenn wir über gemein sind sprechen und
auch die Frage zu welcher
du hast wohl über Utopie gesprochen wo
könnte eigentlich die Reise für uns
langfristig hingehen und es gibt eine
total interessante Zahl dazu seit den
60er Jahren hat das Glück der deutschen
das wird auf verschiedenste Art und
Weise gemessen ich nehme an es geht eher
um Zufriedenheit hat nicht mehr
zugenommen weil alle unmittelbaren
materiellen Bedürfnisse essen trinken
und auch ein bisschen darüber hinaus der
Kühlschrank der Fernseher und so weiter
sind befriedigt aber in derselben Zeit
hat sich das Bruttoinlandsprodukt mehr
als verdoppelt was sagt uns das wenn du
das mal überlegst also wir sind nicht
zufrieden haben wir wir motzen rum und
und sind wahnsinnig unzufrieden du
schreibst in deinem Buch und
interessanten Satz jemand der in den
50er Jahren der Bundesrepublik gelebt
hat der war nicht unbedingt so ein ganz
hundertprozentiger Demokrat aber war
zufrieden
heute sind wir sehr viel überzeugtere
Demokraten aber sind wahnsinnig
unzufrieden das liegt klar das waren die
50er Jahre da hatte man im Hintergrund
ja den Zweiten Weltkrieg ja genau im
Hinterkopf
und dieses Gefühl davon gekommen zu sein
und eines Tages wieder wert zu sein
dieses berühmte wir sind wieder wer nach
das brachte natürlich eine Menge Energie
hervor und auch eine Menge
Übereinstimmung mit dem Land in dem man
lebte
und heute ist es ja tatsächlich so also
es ist allgemein bekannt bedingungslose
wohlstandsmehrung ist keine
bedingungslose glücksmehrung aus einem
ganz einfachen Mechanismus dem vorhin
von mir genannten oder so genannten
kategorischen Komparativ
wenn ich ihn mit einem Einkommen von
3000 Euro habe und mir ein kleines Auto
leisten kann und mir gegenüber ist
jemand der 6000 Euro verdient und
größeres Auto hat dann gibt es eben
viele Menschen die diesen Reflex haben
und sagen wieso habe ich das nicht oder
da muss ich hinkommen
und wenn wir das ganze verzehnfachen und
verhundertfachen bleibt ist das gleiche
das heißt man fängt auch an die
Vergleichsgruppen zu unterscheiden also
Millionäre neigen dazu Urlaub zu machen
wie Millionäre Urlaub machen oder
Milliardäre machen wohnen da wo
Milliardäre wohnen und dieser
kategorische Komparativ der geht nie
verloren
und deswegen ist allein über materielles
Zufriedenheit über einen bestimmten
Punkt hinaus oder Glück nicht mehr von
mir machen aber dann ist doch die Frage
unser System baut ja im Wesentlichen
wirklich auf Geld auf ne es geht um Geld
wir werden belohnt wir machen eigentlich
alles für Geld und Geld ist sozusagen
das einzige Ding
das im Grunde nur in der Quantität gut
ist genau da geht es nie um Qualität
also dessen Qualität sich erleichternder
Quantität bemis exakt das gibt kein so
viele an Geld richtig so aber was macht
dieses ganze Geld was macht das mit
unserem was macht das mit uns
naja sorgt einfach dafür dass in
Gesellschaften die in denen das Geld
diese Wertigkeit hat sich die Menschen
daran orientieren jedenfalls sie alle
allermeisten das ist übrigens ein
klassischer Kritikpunkt von
demokratiegegnern in der Geschichte
das fängt mit Platon an ne der große
berühmte Philosoph Platon ja also so der
bedeutendste Philosoph der Philosophie
Geschichte und auch Aristoteles quasi in
der zweitbedeutendste haben die
Demokratie abgelehnt da steht man doch
vor einem Riesenproblem und sagt wir
konnten diese Intelligenz Bestien und
diese Wegweiser von allem wieso haben
die die Demokratie abgelehnt muss man
sagen dass die Demokratie in den Zeiten
von Platon und aristotel ins unglaublich
schlecht funktionierte die haben die nur
als dysfunktional wahrgenommen
Korruption riesiges Thema ja
wer konnte der hielt sich einen Hofstaat
an
PR-Leuten vorsichtig ausgedrückt deren
Aufgabe darin bestand politische Gegner
zu denunzieren die glücklichste Zeit
Athens war die wo ein Autokrat regierte
namenspericles obwohl man sich
Demokratie nannte also es klappte alles
nicht wirklich und ein entscheidender
Kritikpunkt damals und das taucht
nachher immer wieder auf war das Geld
hat die Ehre ersetzen in der Demokratie
ersetzt das Geld die Ehre diese
Argumentation gibt es auch im 18
Jahrhundert Edmund Burke das ist der
Vater des Konservativismus und der von
mir hier schon mal erzählte wie kommt
debonald der zur Zeit der französischen
Revolution genau dasselbe schreibt
also in einer in einer demokratischen
Gesellschaft besteht immer die Gefahr
dass eine Gesellschaft die vorher über
ihre organisiert wird eine Gesellschaft
entsteht die außer Geld irgendwie keine
Moral mehr kennt jetzt kann man sagen es
gibt ja ganz viele demokratische
Gesellschaften die nicht nur das Geld
zum Wertmaßstab machen da gehört die
Bundesrepublik auch zu dass wir aber in
Gesellschaften vielleicht Leben in der
die Tendenz besteht das ist immer
stärker in diese Richtung geht und dann
ist immer die spannende Frage was sind
die anderen Gegenkräfte die man noch hat
außer dem Geld
und das ist die Gemeinwohl Frage par
excellence wir wollen ja nicht in
unserer Gesellschaft das Geld abschaffen
wir können das ja auch nicht abschaffen
und nicht die Bedeutung des Geldes
sondern wir müssen gucken was ist an ihr
Stelle der Ehre getreten was nicht mit
Geld zu kaufen ist und wenn man das von
der Glücksforschung aussehen würden wir
sofort sagen klar Freundschaft intakte
Beziehung gutes Verhältnis zu seinen
Kindern und so das ist doch alles da
aber was ist auf der Staatsebene also
sonst der großen Ebene da Identifikation
mit einem Gemeinwesen sich einbringen
fürs Gemeinwohl alles das ist
glücksmehrend wie wir wissen und
trotzdem und ist auch etwas was es gibt
ne also jeder dritte Deutsche über 60
ist irgendwie ehrenamtlich engagiert es
ist ja wir leben ja nicht in der Hölle
denn dann der Hölle sondern wir leben da
ja in einer im internationalen Vergleich
gar nicht so schlecht entstehen warum
sie es machen sagen sie dir weil sie
daraus eine tiefe Befriedigung ziehen
und das Thema ich krieg dafür Geld kommt
nie Egoisten im chiese Lynch im Internet
das tun die ja nur weil die Befriedigung
daraus haben wollen da sehen wir dass
dieser egoismusbegriff nicht trägt also
es ist alles da aber was sichert diesen
bestand
wird das so bleiben und dass man sich
diese Fragen in Dringlichkeit stellt ist
natürlich absolut wichtig als gar nicht
darauf zu achten ich finde ja eigentlich
diesen diesen befundene dass das klingt
zur banal wenn man sagt seit den 60er
Jahren hat das Glück der Deutschen nicht
mehr zugenommen in der Wahrnehmung der
Leute aber das Bruttoinlandsprodukt hat
sich mehr als verdoppelt seitdem das ist
ja eigentlich ein ein riesiges Drama das
dahinter steckt wenn man sich das immer
genau überlegt das bedeutet ja übersetzt
so habe ich das für mich interpretiert
das in den 60er Jahren muss irgendwo mal
da waren meine Eltern gerade dabei
sozusagen ihre Existenz zu gründen muss
irgendwo mal an Punkt gewesen sein an
dem die eigentlich ganz zufrieden
gewesen sein müssen naja Menschen sind
ja nicht nur aus materiellen Gründen
unzufrieden dass der Punkt bist du eine
Frage wie gut die er ist oder wie gesund
man ist ja überhaupt also das Leben
sozusagen als ob man etwas tut als
Arbeit aus dem man Freude schöpft oder
nicht schöpft und so also es gibt ja
ganz Faktoren die eine Rolle spielt der
Punkt ist doch wer mir das mit den 60er
Jahren vergleichen würden wir sagen aber
wir haben heute so viele mehr
Möglichkeiten man denke mal die Frauen
gelebt haben welche Rechte sie hatten
möglichst jetzt hat sich alles
verbessert über das Materielle ne
parallel mit dem materiellen hat sich
die Anspruchshaltung an das Leben erhöht
und je höher die Anspruchshaltung an das
Leben umso größer die Gefahr der
unzufrieden wie gesagt weil die Fallhöhe
was damit einhergegangen ist das heißt
also die Ansprüche die man heute hat und
das kann man keinem verdenken ja auf
Glück und auf Sinn und auf Anerkennung
und so ja viel viel höher als die das
flächendeckend in den 60er Jahren war
weißt du was ich so wahnsinnig finde
wenn man sie mit dem Thema beschäftigt
ich frag mich immer wieso hat keiner und
bis heute macht das keiner ich erinnere
mich noch an Angela Merkel die vor ein
paar Jahren gesagt hat naja so wir
werden dafür bezahlt dass dieses Land
wächst zwei bis drei Prozent müssen
schon sein Wachstum Wachstum kam in
jeder Regierungserklärung bei ihr genau
und warum hat damals zu dem Zeitpunkt
also wenn diese 60er Jahre so ein Gefühl
irgendwie verströmt haben bei allen
Unzulänglichkeit was gerade Frauenrecht
und so weiter angesprochen ganz sicher
aber ich rede über das Materielle wenn
es das so ein Gefühl gegeben hat
eigentlich sind die Dinge ganz okay und
wir sind eigentlich ganz zufrieden so
wie es ist was hat dann auch unsere
Politik aber auch uns als Gesellschaft
dazu bewogen nicht einmal diese
Wachstumsideologie mal in Frage zu
stellen weil es nicht geht weil unser
Wirtschaftssystem
nicht weiter existieren kann ohne zu
wachsen das hängt damit zusammen wenn
unsere Ansprüche gleichzeitig gestiegen
sind zum Beispiel unsere Rentenansprüche
ja da muss immer mehr erwirtschaftet
werden um immer mehr Rentner zum
Beispiel zu versorgen unsere gesamten
Sozialkassen Sozialsysteme sind auch
Wachstum ausgerichtet uns richtig dann
gibt es die internationale Konkurrenz
unsere Unternehmen müssen nicht wachsen
weil sie gierig oder böse sind sondern
im internationalen Konkurrenzkampf
bestehen total interessant ist Hubertus
Heil in dieser Woche auf die Frage wo
denn das ganze Geld herkommen soll um
diese Krise jetzt zu bewältigen ja die
großen entlastungspakete und so weiter
sagt es gibt auch eine gute Chance dass
wir aus dieser Krise herauswachsen genau
diesen Begriff benutzt genau das muss
man sagen ich bin ja ich bin ja nicht so
ein Freund von das postwachstumsbegriffs
weil Wachstum ist ja so ein guter
Begriff Pflanzen wachsen man sieht seine
Kinder heranwachsen man wächst an seinen
Herausforderungen ja Leben ist ein
lebenslanges wachsen und dann zu sagen
nee nee mit wachsen muss Schluss sein
das ist ja missverständlich also ein
bildungswachstum finde ich großartig ein
empathiewachstum ist großartig ja ein
Wachstum an sozialen Fähigkeiten und
Fertigkeiten ist großartig also hier
wird der Akzent so ein bisschen schief
gehen und allein dass er materielle
Wachstum der meinen ja nur wo wir vorhin
darüber gesprochen haben die
Vergrößerung des Kuchens
und die Vergrößerung des Kuchens müssen
wir nicht machen weil die Menschen die
richtig sind oder weil sie glücklicher
sein werden wenn der Kuchen größer wird
sondern wir müssen sie aus einem
ökonomischen Zwang heraus machen von dem
auch unser gesamtes Sozialsystem und
damit unser Start abhängig ja und und
wohin das führt es gibt ja ein ganz ganz
berühmtes Beispiel vielfach beschrieben
du beschreibst das auch die Osterinseln
die Geschichte der Osterinseln ja ist
doch eigentlich genau das was im im
großen jetzt sozusagen mit Blick auf den
Planeten passiert ja man muss so bei der
osterinselgeschichte bevor ich die noch
erzähle sagen das rückgaberech waren zum
Beispiel ja sie anders interpretiert ich
sage das gerade vorweg also die
Interpretation dieser Geschichte ist
umstritten
also wir kennen die genauen historischen
Zusammenhänge nicht ich gebe sie aber
jetzt mal wieder weil darauf willst du
hinaus in der Version von Jared Diamond
German Diamond ist ein ganz bedeutender
amerikanischer Evolutionsbiologe der
mehrere Bestseller gestalten großartige
Bücher hatte ein Buch geschrieben das
hat der dritte Schimpanse der meint dass
der Mensch und er hat ein Buch
geschrieben das heißt Kollaps und in
diesem Buch Kollaps warum Zivilisationen
untergehen
er erzählte die Geschichte der
Osterinseln folgendermaßen er sagt die
Osterinseln waren früher komplett
bewaldet
und
irgendwann wurde dieser Wald immer
weiter abgeholzt unter anderem natürlich
erstmal Häuser zu bauen um Holz zu
verfeuern aber auch um diese gewaltigen
Steinstatuen ja die my die jeder kennt
die da drauf sind zu errichten da muss
man große Holzgerüste machen muss auch
die Steine mit Hilfe von Holz zu rollen
vorwärts bewegen und das Interessante
ist als der niederländische Seefahrer
Jakob von roggewinn die Osterinseln
entdeckte ja es war ausgerechnet ein
Ostersonntag deswegen heißen die so 18
Jahrhundert da fragte er sich wie waren
die denn in der Lage diese gigantischen
Steinskulpturen zu machen es gibt doch
keinen Wald mehr auf der Insel und er
fand die Zivilisation auf den
Osterinseln armselig und schäbig und er
konnte sich gar nicht vorstellen dass
diese halb ausgehungerten gestalten die
da zum Teil Ratten und sowas gegessen
haben weil es keine Lebensgrundlagen
mehr gab in der Lage waren so eine
Kultur hervorzuzaubern das war übrigens
die Vorlage dafür dass Erich von Däniken
war der einzige der die richtige
Erklärung gefunden
die die errichtet haben in seinem Buch
Beweise ja das ausführlich erzählt
die Pointe daran ist Jared Diamond
stellt eine Frage er sagt was dachte
wohl der Osterinsulaner der den letzten
Baum fällt so und die Frage finde ich
uninteressant der wird gedacht haben man
hat schon immer Bäume gefällt und auf
einen Baum mehr oder wenig kommt es am
Ende nicht mehr an die richtig spannende
Frage für unsere Kultur ist
ab welchem Punkt hätten die
Osterinsulaner aufhören müssen ihren
Wald zu roden also wann war die
Generation da wo man gesagt hat stoppt
jetzt können wir nicht mehr und der
Punkt ist dieser Punkt kommt nicht
denn jemand der damit aufwächst als Kind
das ist 50 Prozent Wald gibt ja und dann
dessen Lebensende ist noch 40% bald gibt
der glaubt nicht dass ein großen Schaden
angerichtet hat muss richtig und der
denkt auch nicht es ist an ihm damit
aufzuhören und in der nächsten
Generation geht es die nächsten zehn
Prozent weiter und genau in diesem
Prozess befinden wir uns ja und wir
müssen dringend aufhören noch einen
einzigen Baum umzuhacken und wir sehen
im Augenblick es geht nicht wir werden
unter Umständen wieder mehr Kohle
verbrennen und so weiter also werden
genau die Dinge tun die wir nicht mehr
tun können weil unsere Politiker aus
einer ganzen Reihe von Gründen sagen es
können wir im Augenblick nicht machen
aber ich glaube im nächsten Augenblick
können wir es wieder nicht machen und
dem übernächsten können wir es auch
nicht hören das heißt wir finden wie die
Osterinsulaner in der Diamond Geschichte
nie den richtigen Punkt das meine ich ja
und das und wann ist der Punkt gekommen
an dem Du sagen musst okay pass auf
Wachstum um jeden Preis ja
Bruttoinlandsprodukt immer zwei drei
Prozent jedes da versus Gemeinwohl weil
darum geht es ja also an welchem Punkt
hast du sozusagen das große Ganze im
Blick und an welchem Punkt bist du so
Visionär zu verstehen dass das jetzt
wichtiger ist als alles andere das
könntest du dann wenn du verdammt gute
andere Ideen hättest zum Beispiel wie Du
unser Sozialsystem finanzierst wenn du
da keine andere Idee hast als das wie
bisher über Arbeit zu finanzieren da
sind wir beim Lieblingsthema
Grundeinkommen wie finanziert man das
was den künftige Steuerquellen die
vielleicht neben die Besteuerung von
Arbeit treten können über diese Dinge
müsste man nachdenken um überhaupt in
der Lage sein Alternativen vorzuschlagen
das größte Problem unsere Regierung ist
dass sie sie alternativlos während ihr
fällt nichts anderes ein und wenn sie
mit Ideen konfrontiert wird es gibt ja
genug
dann denken die Politiker im ein oder
anderen Fall und das weiß ich auch aus
persönlichen Gesprächen das könnte ein
guter Weg sein aber gleichzeitig wissen
sie dass kann ich jetzt und hier nicht
durchsetzen
sie wissen genau praktisch pragmatisch
kann ich jetzt damit nicht kommen und da
sind wir wieder bei der Osterinsel weil
die nächsten politiker können jetzt auch
wieder nicht exakt dass der so
verschieben wir diese Reformen die am
Ende in eine dramatische Situation
führen können wenn wir sie nicht machen
deswegen glaube ich ja auch wenn man
sich mit diesem Thema beschäftigt und
abschließend noch mal kurz der Gedanke
dass wir auch
wir haben ja immer so das Gefühl
Politiker müssen bessere Menschen sein
dass wir selbst aber die Wahrheit ist
wie überschätzen die die sind genauso
wie wir und und wir sollten Sie auch
nicht überfordern mit dem was wir in
abverlangen sondern wir sollten
eigentlich irgendwann mal überlegen
gewisse kommen denn selber gegensteuern
was können wir denn eigentlich selber
tun müssen wir immer wirklich nach dem
Staat rufen oder müssen wir immer mal
sagen im Sinne des Gemeinsinns des
Gemeinwohls lass uns der Dinge selbst in
die Hand nehmen du kannst der richtige
Punkt ist ist sicher ein sowohl als auch
also ich misstraue natürlich auch der
graswurzel Ideologie wenn jeder bei sich
selber anfängt wird die Welt besser
und auf der anderen Seite bin ich völlig
bei dir zu sagen man kann ich in jeder
Frage nach dem Staat rufen
also vieles zumindestens im kommunalen
oder regionalen
ließe sich selbst erfolgreicher auf die
Beine stellen vieles ließe sich machen
und die größte Bedrohung auf der Ebene
ist im Regelfall die Bürokratie
ganz vieles davon und kann man nicht und
das geht aus juristischen Gründen nicht
und so weiter also da könnte ich
zahlreiche Beispiele dafür aufzählen und
am Ende lande ich wieder bei Rupert
Neudeck wenn du irgendwas in der Welt
besser machen
genau aber es gibt ein schönes Beispiel
in deinem Buch Rathenauplatz in Köln ja
genau da habe ich ja mal gewohnt ganz
unmittelbar am Rathenauplatz also
wunderschöner Platz in Köln wirklich ich
glaube der schönste Platz Köln das kann
man wirklich sagen wirkt so Französisch
irgendwie und dieser Platz war in der
80er Jahre als ich nach Köln kam und
dort wohnte total verwahrlost also
Obdachlose waren da und sehr viele fixer
meines war so eine Frage ob man im
Dunkeln dahin gehen sollte und es war
alles vollkommen und dann haben die
Anwohner gesagt die in so sehr schön
auch eher verkommenen Gründerzeit
Häusern wohnten sehr studentisch
die Stadt gefragt kann man nicht mal was
machen und die Stadt gesagt kein Geld
und dann haben die Anwohner das selber
gemacht und eine Bürgerinitiative
gegründet und dann haben die also nicht
nur den den Park super gemacht riesigen
Spielplatz darauf angelegt die haben
eine Gastronomie selbst eingerichtet
eine eine kleine Holzhütte dahin gesetzt
die sogar ein Architekturpreis gewonnen
hat sich dann aber vor dem Problem
gesehen dass plötzlich eine mieten
Explosion stattfand weil der
rathenowplatz so attraktiv wurde dann
haben Sie sich für mietschutz eingesetzt
und so weiter also wirklich großartiges
geleistete Rathenauplatz ist immer noch
wunderbar und wunderschön
aber man kann nicht sagen dass dieser
Bürgerinitiative auf diesem Weg nicht
hundert Steine in den Weg gelegt wurden
auch und manchmal sie von Seiten der
Stadt so nach dem Motto wo kämen wir hin
wenn das jeder machen würde und ich habe
immer gedacht es wäre großartig wenn das
jedoch machen würde also
Richard dank Dessert aber interessant
mit dir mal über Gemeinsinn zu sprechen
ich glaube da haben wir also dieses
Umdenken im Kopf das das wird noch lange
brauchen lange dauern und ich glaube am
Ende aber in 20 30 vielleicht auch 50
Jahren wenn da ganz andere Lösungen ganz
andere Systeme stehen das glaube ich
auch ich glaube dass wir uns tatsächlich
in einer großen Transformationszeit
befinden wo wir gerade am Anfang stehen
und ich setze darauf dass Dinge die am
Anfang zäh und langsam gehen aber einen
bestimmten Punkt sich rasant
beschleunigen und wir haben im
Augenblick das historische Zeitfenster
und das müssen immer Krisen sein ja
sonst passiert nichts das historische
Zeitfenster wirklich viel zu verändern
aber wir müssen es eben auch tun und die
richtige Mischung guten Ideen und
Pragmatismus das ist es worauf es
ankommt Richard dank Dessert ich danke
dir bis bald ja ciao
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]